[Music]
we're breaking into scheduled
programming to take you live to occupied
east jerusalem where the body of our
colleague shireen abu akley who was
killed by israeli forces on wednesday
is
being moved from the hospital
where it has been kept overnight
in readiness for her funeral
in just a few hours from now
let's listen in
danny
but we'll stay up with the pictures uh
for
the moment
uh as i said a funeral will be held in
the coming hours for our colleague
shireen abu akley who was killed by
israeli forces on wednesday uh the
service at a church in occupied east
jerusalem
follows a state memorial with
palestinian leaders and foreign
diplomats among the thousands who
attended that was on thursday
shireen just a reminder was shot in the
head by israeli forces in the occupied
west bank on wednesday president mahmoud
abbas has promised to seek justice
for her death
at the international criminal court
in the next couple of hours we'll be
taking uh the funeral service live here
and the procession as shireen's coffin
is carried
to the church later she will be laid to
rest
in the graveyard which contains
uh the graves of her parents
while we watch these pictures let me
just remind you that israel has carried
out further raids in janine
in the occupied west bank where
shireen was
murdered
on wednesday 11 people have been injured
including two who were shot
dozens have been killed during israeli
operations in the city since march this
year and israel says that its actions
are in response to
palestinian attacks
let's um hear now from my colleague
ibrahim who
is going to remind us of
yesterday's
service in ramallah
leader is in the occupied west bank
[Music]
thousands gather to pay the respects
her remains then taken to a state
service
where the palestinian president honored
her
he vowed to seek justice at the
international criminal court
today we are here to pay our respect to
shireen abu akhla the martyr of
palestine the martyr of jerusalem and
the martyr of free speech and the free
world
a symbol of the palestinian women a
symbol of the palestinian journalists
shireen has sacrificed her life to
defend its course and the cause of the
palestinian people
shireen worked for al jazeera and was
widely known for reporting on the
israel-palestine conflict for more than
two decades
everyone standing here has his own story
with syrian
as friends we experienced with her this
amazing person pure soul
and
innocent
professional journalist we always waited
for shireen to tell us the story we're
losing today a great storyteller we've
never
expected that outpour of love
we know she's known we know she's a star
we know she's famous
but for people to be stopping the convoy
coming from the hospital
throwing roses at her casket
it's hard to put words to
what every palestinian is feeling today
she was shot in the head and killed
instantly in the occupied west bank on
wednesday
[Music]
her colleague seen to the right is shada
haneshi she says the attack on her team
was intended to kill
the occupation forces led us to reach
that point where they fired on us i want
to tell her that i'm sorry i couldn't
protect you when we were under fire i
failed to save you
israel's government initially said
palestinian fighters were to blame but
that was disputed by witnesses
journalists and rights groups
this is the moment where there's going
to be the most outpouring of outrage and
grief about the killing of shireen so if
they can cast doubt if they can muddy
waters around the death of shireen by
possibly getting newspapers in the
international sphere to suggest that she
was killed by a palestinian they have
been successful
israel says it will investigate
sharing's killing and offered to do it
in conjunction with palestinian
officials
the palestinian president said he would
not cooperate with israel
we refused any joint investigation
committee with israeli authorities
because they have committed such a crime
we don't trust them and will go
immediately to the international
criminal court in order to find the
perpetrators and criminals
al jazeera media network has described
the 51 year old's death as blatant
murder making clear it holds israel
responsible
shireen's body was then taken from
ramallah through the kalindia checkpoint
to jerusalem where she was born
on friday there will be a funeral
service in jerusalem the very place
shireen was proud to call home
ibrahim
okay let's uh
take you back uh to occupy east
jerusalem this was just a short while
ago
uh the body of our colleague sharin abu
akley who was murdered by israeli forces
on wednesday this week
has laid overnight in a watery at a
hospital
it is
now about to be moved
and
carried to
a church in occupied east jerusalem
where a funeral service will be held
before
shireen is
laid to rest alongside her parents
in a rather followed a state memorial
with palestinian leaders and foreign
diplomats
among the thousands who attended
[Applause]
this is al jazeera live from doha
it is 10 hours gmt
a funeral will be held in the coming
hours for al jazeera journalist shabeen
abu akley who was killed by israeli
forces on wednesday the service at a
church in occupied east jerusalem
follows a state memorial with
palestinian leaders and foreign
diplomats among the thousands who
attended shereen was shot
in the head by israeli forces in the
occupied west bank on wednesday
president mahmoud abbas has promised to
seek justice at the international
criminal court
shireen's body is being moved from the
mortuary where it is laying overnight
uh ready for the funeral service which
will begin within the next hour al
jazeera's imran khan is near the church
in the occupied in occupied east
jerusalem where that funeral will be
held
imran just run us through what's due to
happen today
well the church is just down that street
it's a very key turkish church it's the
greek patriarch a church a very
important church here in occupied east
jerusalem uh where the body is currently
in the morgue is about a half hour 45
minute walk from where i'm standing
right now that's where the procession
will begin they'll come here there'll be
a funeral service inside that church and
then they'll move to mount zion which is
where shireen's body will be finally
laid to rest but let me just show you
i'm just going to get out the way so we
can see up that street you'll see
flags of shireen that are just placed
in the street over there
those flags actually say the world does
not end may shireen rest in peace those
flags and pictures of her are all down
that street but in other areas of
occupied east jerusalem
those pictures have actually been taken
down by the police the police have not
allowed palestinians to show their grief
in that manner we're also expecting uh
in another part of east jerusalem
occupied east jerusalem in damascus gate
a small protest by local journalists
as a memorial service as well to take
place but like i say all of this is in
the next few hours but uh there is a
heavy police presence here not a visible
one but we are being told that there is
a very heavy police operation uh in
place uh here in jaffa gate in occupied
east jerusalem and after denying that
its personnel were responsible for
shabeen's murder there are now reports
imran that uh the israeli army is
investigating its soldiers
that's right according to a report by
the washington post a anonymous israeli
army official has been speaking to their
journalists he says that there is three
investigations taking place now reid uh
three soldiers are being investigated
their guns their weapons have been taken
away that anonymous source actually goes
on to say that it's likely one of those
three soldiers will be responsible for
sharing
killing now we reached out
to the israeli army for comment on that
story so far they haven't given us any
statement right now so uh there's no
official confirmation of that the
palestinians however are hanging on to
the actual bullets that killed uh
sharing they don't trust the israelis to
mount an independent investigation
indeed as you said before the
palestinians are looking to the
international criminal court for an
investigation they're also calling for
the international community to put
pressure on israel
to allow an international investigation
to take place all right for the moment
imran many thanks indeed after zeros
imran khan there in occupied east
jerusalem uh not far away from imran is
al jazeera's stephanie decker steph
you're at the cemetery
where shireen will be laid to rest a
little later
that's right her body will be taken as
you mentioned there from the morgue the
hospital going to where imran is the
service will be held at the church
within the walls of the of the old city
and then it will be making uh its way
here so also she'll be laid to rest
beside uh her parents so her mother
lying here passed away in 1998 her
father in 2000 so this in the very early
stages of shading's career they never
would have seen just how successful how
loved how respected she became she will
then be laid to rest uh here next to her
parents um and that'll be her final
resting place we're expecting really
thousands and thousands of people uh to
show up adrian the the outpour of love
and respect for sheree not just from her
colleagues and the media here and those
of of us who knew her but people who've
been watching her for over 20 years
really feeling this as a as a deep
personal tragedy and a deep personal
loss so at the moment uh this cemetery
very beautiful very peaceful is empty
but i think within you know two or three
hours this will be absolutely packed as
people try to come in to pay their final
respects and what is the timing on on
this step when are we expecting all of
this to happen today
well the body is expected to move in
about let's say 17 minutes from now
making its way um from the morgue to uh
the greek patriarch church the ceremony
perhaps taking around an hour less so
and then making its way here so i would
say we will probably see her body arrive
here in a couple of hours from now two
to three hours from now
so it will still take some time but i do
think
we're going to see tens of thousands of
people everyone i've spoken to that i
know here people are working
that can't attend but certainly even
people in the hotel room staying very
moved everyone everyone aware about
what's happening today and you know it's
rare that you see the streets here in
jerusalem
full of people in the sense when there's
tensions you know the only thing really
that has the ability to bring mass
crowds to the street is tensions over
the al-aqsa mosque compound we were
discussing with our colleagues today we
think that what we're going to see today
in terms of turnout of people on the
streets is something that we probably
haven't seen
um in a long time again we'll have to
wait and see but from the outpouring of
grief and respect and love for her i
think everyone who can will try and and
come to pay their respects all right
stephanie thanks indeed i don't just
stephanie decker there live in occupied
east jerusalem let's take you now to
ramallah uh al jazeera's sami zedan is
uh there sammy tell us more about that
we were talking with steph there about
this this outpouring of of grief that
it's been the sense of shock
that that people are still feeling ahead
of sharim's funeral today
absolutely and that continues here in
ramallah which is of course in the west
bank a very important
city in the west bank it's where the
palestinian authorities government
offices are currently seated
in a word shock and disbelief
the somberness of the mood you can feel
it here you can might even be able to
hear it behind me you've got the more
evident
making the traditional run-up
announcements to friday prayers but it
kind of takes on a special symbolic
feeling today because
as that call rings out here and echoes
you can also see the picture of
sharina bakla on that big screen behind
me here in ramallah's main square you
can see her picture in photos
and you talk to people and they talk
about her they remember her like a
member of the family that screen
let me just tell you what it says there
it says goodbye
to the voice of palestine
that is a nickname that people
used to refer to her by as the voice of
palestine so you can get an
understanding of how shocking it was for
people to contrast this iconic figure
with the image of her lying face down
after having been shot i think it's not
an exaggeration to say what we're
witnessing here
is the transition from an icon a symbol
into a legend
adrian all right samia many thanks
indeed sammy zaydan there live in
ramallah let's show you once again the
live pictures uh from the hospital where
sharim's body
lay overnight
uh it is due as uh my colleague
stephanie decker told us a few moments
ago
uh to be taken from the mortuary there
at the hospital uh within the next hour
uh to that funeral service uh before
shireen will be laid to rest
uh in that graveyard we saw a few
moments ago
in occupied east jerusalem